thank you
[Music]
welcome back to other careful boys we're
very careful boys I'm gonna say it
quicker because we're in a short one
today we're talking about do you believe
in aliens do you [ __ ] believe oh wow
yeah what's your definition of an alien
alien would be like someone who comes up
here from Mexico without even not even
going to talk oh I Hail To Believe In
Those okay I love it yeah I've seen a
couple dude oh my bad I don't know if
that's the right word for it you talking
to meet more aliens
I believe in aliens
how are you gonna have these [ __ ]
pyramids all over the world they don't
know how to talk to each other are you
thinking pyramids are related let's go
the pyramid again
that's an alien structure across the
world they didn't talk to each other
here they don't got no DMS and shin
ships and they put a point to the same
[ __ ] constellations in the [ __ ]
Sky how do they do it do you ever think
about how maybe a guy like probably was
not good at promoting himself back then
and he probably found like all this he
probably like set sail and mcfallon [ __ ]
like spread a bunch of information but
he's not good at promoting himself like
Christopher Columbus was like his own
height dad he's a girl like who [ __ ]
found all this [ __ ] Chris Columbus
right and everyone's and then he got his
shipmacist and he's like yeah see that's
what's up but then this guy's just like
kind of humble he's more like Nick likes
yeah I'm gonna talk about his
accomplishments he's like yeah like I
don't know I did this thing like him in
second place like in the world but like
you know I probably shouldn't talk about
it right like you know what I mean maybe
he's just they're not hype Manning it
hard enough so maybe a guy just spread
information with a boat by the way Bart
not the [ __ ] hardback then just float
around
that's actually a really good theory
thank you I was someone that just like
was quiet a genius who learned how to
build the Pyramid just a guy by himself
nah but like you know with his his Squad
of like six people let's just say six
people they had to have like [ __ ] 600
000 people or six million people
building those [ __ ] pyramids or
whatever you think couple of them didn't
set sail somewhere yeah what about this
what about these [ __ ] are
sleeping in the dirt because they're so
[ __ ] dumb and the pyramids are so
precisely engineered you can't even
stick a piece of paper between the two
bricks how about that maybe they're
really good Engineers but they're not
really good at like interior designs and
they're like [ __ ] their sisters and
[ __ ]
they just took the [ __ ] sisters
they're not the smartest people what do
I think about that though maybe they're
just showing you the one brick you can't
stick a piece of paper between it I I
see those pyramids dude this looks like
you can stick out there's some gaps it
looks like a fire fire paper airplane
through some of that [ __ ] you're just
talking about I guess we're zooming in
on one picture being like see you can't
that's that one brick you can't [ __ ]
do it see that are you saying you don't
believe in aliens I'm saying I don't
believe the pyramids are real
for the pyramids whoever built the
pyramids you think it was more likely
that it was a human being and not aliens
I I dude I think we could handle making
that [ __ ] pyramid
I think we could [ __ ] head up he's
like have you seen Luxor exactly
break what do you think you believe it
yeah it's from outer space uh
um well I asked you what your definition
of an alien is because some people think
it's just like certain molecules it
could be it's not a sexier fun like a
tardigrade wait do you guys believe in
microbiology
people are like unsexy conversations
here we go well technically that's an
alien they did survive very very hot
temperatures and no oxygen but are you
like an alien that could look like us or
something different or human right a
sentient being from another planet Earth
a sentient beam yeah let's go for a
sentient Bean okay maybe he has
depression probably anxiety a lot of
anxiety yeah
gave birth to cal-l he has eczema on his
elbows
the dry skin just I believe in woke
aliens aliens
is this is it is there some new thing
about aliens or anything short OTR I'm
wondering is there something you just
brought it up I was curious he likes
aliens
how about this yes there is do so no you
guys remember you guys remember when we
hit that asteroid recently yeah yeah
there was apparently some micro biology
okay now we want to talk about it there
you go so there's some [ __ ] cells or
some [ __ ] on that microbiology [ __ ]
little tiny little tiny little little
buddies I also think we're engineered
aminals oh [ __ ] yeah engineered by who
don't put your mouth I don't know but so
there's a there's a weird coincidence we
got dolphin skin right we got [ __ ]
lungs and [ __ ] and we look really close
to monkeys but for some reason we got
all these extra skills so I kind of feel
like aliens came down and then goes
Hocus Pocus build me some pyramids and
they're able to make us super smart
animals to do whatever the [ __ ] they
want us to do and then bounce why if I'm
an alien I came here from God knows
where outside the Milky Way whatever yep
why do I need you to build me a pyramid
I don't know what they're trying to do
trying to [ __ ] get didn't they say it
was that energy Thing One Thing
harnessing energy in a certain way with
those pyramids back in the day really
what do you think aliens would think
about it sounds sick now right now if
they came back and they're like oh look
what happened to them 2000 years later
you had an alien aliens on this this if
they talk to Joe Biden I think they
would say that we're pretty awesome
I think that they would be like yeah we
did it if we if they made us like yeah
[ __ ] yeah we did it
there's always those talks about aliens
like [ __ ] flying around uh areas that
have like nuclear missiles and [ __ ] like
that because they're like conscious
about our our energy and our willingness
to destroy each other but if they had
come here like in ancient times and
given us knowledge and stuff only to see
us like [ __ ] up our own like society and
our own Planet they sometimes come in
order to make sure that we're not like
you know they're neutralizing those
threats they're like jamming the [ __ ]
computers and radio waves and stuff so
that nukes can't be sent out so my
[ __ ] modem doesn't work when I need
it to that's Spectrum bro but why do we
believe that aliens will typically have
a better moral compass than we do like
what if they come here because they're
way more woke than we are yeah thank you
for proving my point
what we just got those guys like
thousands of years than us they're woke
[ __ ] is like they turned on each other a
long time ago they've been walked dude
yeah that's why they're here they're
like our whole planet was canceled
so that's why they came trying to teach
us to not have microaggressions when we
talk aliens that come here are like the
the people that we sent to like
Australia back in the day right it's
just like Earth is like that spot for
aliens do you think the aliens come here
and like I want to talk to your leader
but I have a lot of anxiety
that's why they're just peeking they're
just checking it out and they're like we
gotta go we gotta go what do I do and
they leave yeah unless aliens are
already here I bet they are do you guys
believe in aliens yesterday
I think you're pretty much a [ __ ]
idiot if you don't believe anything
about that so are you are you an idiot
or not
are you an idiot
he's thinking I believe in aliens what
about you Ryan you believe in agents I
yeah well I believe in in that what
we've learned about the observable
universe
sick answer it's just it's inevitable
that the probability sways in the yes
side but it's not like I don't I don't
think humans have gone
I don't think we know
well um witness one do you believe in
all the in our time are we gonna make
enough time I don't think so do you
believe in all the Bob Lazar stuff yeah
yeah
S4 what's the deal with bobbles all that
stuff do you think is legit can you give
us a cliff notes that Bob those are hey
maybe this is gonna be a long note here
yeah no let's make it long like the
general public won't know maybe people
up in government and high sectors
because everybody puts a lot of
credibility behind Bob Lazar story they
do but there's problems there's a couple
problems with it I do honestly I [ __ ]
believe what's the problem with what's
the problem right now but no the
problems with this story are just that
um he he says that he he got some of the
material like the one what was it um
Element 115 something like that yeah he
says that he got some it's like dude
just [ __ ] jealous let's see it if you
want why do you think it's at his house
in the fridge or something he won't say
where it is but you could show a lot of
people the absolute [ __ ] up if you
actually have some what's the
significance of element 115. I'm in 115
he says is what powers the craft that
they use and it's not from this world
well it's it's synthesis yeah but now
they can make it I said yeah but it's
not naturally occurring here exactly but
now we made it what happened to element
number one through 114
they don't know I mean they're on the
they're on the periodic table still
all 114 of them yeah I don't know how
many that are yeah dude no you could
have predicted that 115 would exist but
you wouldn't know that it would have the
super heavy isotope and that's what he
predicted and he was right he put it
down like the [ __ ] early 80s with her
heavy ice what happens if he shows it is
there a threat if he like then then
Jesus can't come back exactly that's not
what he's worried about I don't know
that's the thing I don't know but like
he could settle a lot of [ __ ] like you
want to talk [ __ ] about babazar he could
settle it by producing that's a lot of
anxiety on his shoulder he's like dude I
can settle this [ __ ] or if I do this
though Jesus won't come back yeah that's
true and or I'll get murked for showing
people this that could be and he was
threatened definitely like that's what
he says right and um there's other
people who corroborate his story like
George Knapp who looked like a [ __ ]
psychopath for years he used to be on
Art Bell you guys ever listen to The
Coast to Coast AM yeah this is the
greatest show ever I used to do when I
was a kid
um but he was on there all the time
George he was talking about Balthazar
back then and he's talking about all the
kinds of stuff that he's researched but
they kind of turned him into a cracker
do whackpot crack job because he was
hanging out like with those types
because those the only people who would
[ __ ] listen to him at the time but
now that like our government's disclosed
like yeah we have you know uavs now
right unidentified aerial whatever or
atip exists right where they they
researched that stuff they got that that
guy Lou Elizondo he he's like got this
bunch of tattoos that he comes out and
he's like yeah they've been looking at
UFOs for [ __ ] years we don't know
what they are and that's all he knows so
far well that's all he I thought it was
just a time traveling tourists could
honestly be or that guy from Blink 182
doesn't he [ __ ] does he need like a
UFO yeah it's always him it is him
he like started [ __ ] organizations
and [ __ ] regarding like since the CIA
was telling him [ __ ] he took that on Joe
Rogan years ago I saw a clip about it
yeah you think he's full of [ __ ] Tom
Delong I dude I [ __ ] don't know
that's the thing you just don't know
who's full of [ __ ] who's not
until you do
apparently until you do I'm willing to
bet that there's some aliens out there
dude I think everyone should be because
it's no just me you can just keep
looking until you find him it's [ __ ]
infinite the universe you think they're
from The Zeta reticulous tolerance
system I don't know what the [ __ ] you
said
Bob ozar says that he was told he
doesn't know that it's true but he was
given information that they said that
this is they're from The Zeta reticulate
star system and again he maybe thinks
this could have been disinformation
they're giving him like good information
with bad information to see if he's
gonna leak [ __ ] and then they'll know
who leaked it because he said what right
who knows oh that's the game see that's
the hard part right so you never know
what the [ __ ] is up you know the only
thing that I don't like enjoy about this
whole alien thing is
we never get HD footage of [ __ ] okay
every single time you see like a UFO
rant it's like always grainy blurry and
we just live in this Mitch Hedberg said
it well he's just like you know Bigfoot
exists I just think he's blurry
you know what I mean yeah and it's like
that's why we need Colleen's red camera
all the [ __ ] Tech that we have and
every single time we see one of these
things it's always like questionably
Blurry and that's the only thing that
bugs me well what do you think the
probability is that when an alien shows
up someone with like a DSLR or some [ __ ]
has a [ __ ] camera yeah that's why we
need Colleen to always shoot the sky
yeah to be fair I think the
possibilities in today's world
especially with everybody technically
has more Tech and Camera capabilities
and the same [ __ ] that [ __ ] Santa
Paula to the moon like they choose 420p
yeah you know I think yeah I think we
can get something oh [ __ ] mainly at 420.
native if you capture it you when by the
time we want to broadcast you probably
gotta zoom in 20 times so it looks like
[ __ ] anyway it's all blurry bro what
what did some sick ass camera for a
portrait mode you gotta get closer you
can't do that I told you guys I saw UFO
in the 90s right did you yeah 100 saw
UFO 1996 Flagstaff Arizona I was driving
here from Fairfax Virginia we were
moving to California and we saw this
[ __ ] light all the way up in the sky
like hi hi hi right and it's just
sitting it's just chilling there
completely not moving and the Sun is
hitting it so it's like metal it's like
reflecting or I don't know if it's metal
but it's like reflecting like it's metal
right and then it's just chilling there
and we're watching it for probably 15
minutes because we're just driving and
it's like in that direction and then was
it a weird shape it was it was just so
high I mean it was just a complete
perfect circle right like from because
on seeing the the light hit it right so
I don't exactly know what it shape is
because the light's hitting it so hard
but um like there's not a cloud in the
whole [ __ ] it's completely Blue
Desert Sky right and then after like 15
minutes my whole family's looking at my
grandma my sister
everybody's looking at right and then
all of a sudden out of nowhere a cloud
forms around it and I'm not getting and
it it sucked inside of itself and like
left this like residual Cloud that's the
purple Infinity that's what when Thanos
use into the cloud it looks like that it
looked well I mean you know that's
that's a really high high def version of
what I saw like but it was like way far
away right okay yeah yeah okay it was so
far away but it was it was like Cloud
around it sucks inside of itself we all
saw the same thing it was [ __ ] crazy
well do you think that was what sparked
your interest in UFOs when you saw that
no I definitely you were like balls deep
in UFOs I was in balls deep but ever
since I saw Independence Day which was
just like it was the scene it was
everyone's Gateway is that what sparked
your hatred for weather balloons
dude Roswell did bro Roswell did
Independence Day was sick AF it was
defense [ __ ] dude it's one of the best
movies ever dude ever I wish the secret
we saw it at the right age too I should
have just never made it they should have
never made the sequel no but watching
that movie you feel like a [ __ ] kid
I'll fight for our country
I love that it becomes and you're also
you're also like dude like a soccer
alien dude I bunch of alien in the
[ __ ] face when he's all rocked and he
crashes a ship you know not one-on-one
combat okay they do make some of that
stuff seem
um you know the way is obviously it's
[ __ ] a movie but the way they tie in
all those things that you're already
curious about right it's like is there a
[ __ ] Area 51 does the government know
about and the president himself does it
yeah it doesn't know you're kind of like
wait a minute I guess that could make
sense yeah
that's what the word is right is that
um after World War II presidents were
asking about what's going on in Area 51
and I guess uh [ __ ] what's his name
uh not Truman Jerry O'Connell not Joe
O'Connell his brother one of the one of
the presidents was like hey brothers I
want I want to know what's going on at
Area 51 and they're like you don't have
need to know right this is like above
your clearance level and then he
threatened to send the military
was it one of the bushes it wasn't one
of the bushes earlier yeah resident
didn't have enough clearance yeah it was
a president it was a president I don't
remember who was it true
that's [ __ ] crazy I do remember that
though I feel like you can't trust the
president dude and then they call that
the Majestic group or Majestic 12 which
is like the group that's like above
above above like clearance and like you
you like only like a couple people even
know about it see I love the idea of
clearance you know what I mean yeah like
that's cool already apparently Bill
Clinton also revealed that he sent a
team to Area 51 to make sure there were
no aliens in 2022. he was freaking out
what
yeah this week revealed he sent his
National Security advisor to inspect
Area 51 in Nevada for aliens that's
crazy why wouldn't you go I just go when
you go
Obama acknowledged the existence of Area
51 in 2013. well it was already it was
already Declassified by then they had
already admitted it in the I think late
90s is when they actually said yeah air
51 exists and what do they say about it
like what's in a test range
they work on technology that they don't
want other countries to know they're
working on so it makes sense if that's
you know it's alien they bought acres
and Acres but what's all this stuff
about the butt probing and Aliens like
where the [ __ ] did that come like all
the Rednecks always say my butt got
touched yeah like well there's got to be
some truth rumors right I think so if
there's a Common Thread wishful thinking
combined with hallucinations wishful
thinking if you're an alien though let
me ask you this how about this yeah
if you're an alien and you want to
abduct someone and then you want them to
tell a story that no one will believe
[Music]
[Laughter]
where I'm going with this wouldn't you
get him to do some crazy [ __ ]
you don't even need them to do yeah like
hey uh we need you to jerk off in this
silver dish
I think I was like what the [ __ ] yeah
we're gonna need you to jerk it pretty
good and we need to jerk it and come in
the silver dish it's pretty it's pretty
smart [ __ ] hair samples and [ __ ]
whatever it's smart as hell because
probing something up your ass is
timeless like the first guy said that
[ __ ] decades ago and it's still funny
that's true it's still sticking around
they're smart enough to know that this
is gonna work yeah like doesn't get old
humans will never believe they didn't
even Discover it they thought it was a
theory for a long time that the male
prostate was all the way up there yeah
but then in the early 60s yeah just
after Roswell that's when it first
started again that's when I started you
know yeah allocated some budget into
that study started exploring it it
started pressing on it but probably is
Evergreen so yeah it's always going to
be a good business always going to be
good yeah it's always going to stem a
lot of content from like butt probing
yeah I think so what's your butt probing
business idea
I don't know maybe like an escape room
type of deal okay like an alien themed
escape room okay and do I sign a waiver
yeah for sure because my my thing about
Escape rooms is there's never high
enough Stakes but there's no escape from
the probing
what if you're okay with it then that's
fine then it's a win-win for everyone
then you're turned away at the door
because the one thing about Escape rooms
is when I when they give me a brain
teaser I'm like I don't give a [ __ ] dude
like you eventually you don't care and
then you're just like all right what's
this group of people doing and you kind
of like [ __ ] around you've been in there
not caring a little bit a little bit
dude that's my whole problem I had that
problem with escape room I went to one
escape room I think that ruined it for
me because it was so cool and so
immersive and like you had to like reach
under things and like pull like it just
worked it was the best ones yeah the
best ones and then I went to one where
just like brain teasers figure it out
what's this number divisible by it I'm
like oh no that sucks guys guys I found
triangles are linked together you might
as well like rip the pages out of a
Highlights magazine just wrap my head in
it yeah dude I was like I paid money for
this I like paid money I appreciate and
there's no butt plug there's no high
stakes then I'm not gonna solve this
puzzle I think you're good at this there
was a really good a good one in in uh
like right around the corner from here
it closed down exit game yeah that's the
one I did that was lit did you go to the
North Korea base it was so good you did
that one the kid Kim jong-il's like on a
screen I'm talking [ __ ] I thought it was
David so actually for a while it's so
good he's like you can't defuse my bomb
I thought that was David so
[Music]